hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
understanding how in vitro macrophage
assays drive
i o drug development forward i am
jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by miltonia biotech
to learn more visit noteenhebiotech.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind
everyone that today's event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions
as you want at any time at any time you
want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker dr tibo
jantz senior scientist at immune experts
and nexellus group company for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr james you
may now begin your presentation
hello everyone and welcome to this
webinar
i'm tiborians i'm a senior scientist at
the immune expert
next year group company so first i would
like to give you a bit of a background
about the company history
so immune expert was found in 2014 by
sophie paten
together with felistas and arnold
romingay
and first the company was focusing on a
in vitro immediacy assay
then in 2016 with the booming of the
immunology development
and for example the checkpoint inhibitor
field
the company expands to in vitro
functional and potency essay
for higher drugs in 2017 we moved to new
dedicated facilities
and we currently have more than 17
colleagues we have been working on 200
projects
for more than 70 customers in 18
countries
in march this year we have been acquired
by the nexeles group
a world leading provider of services
with more than 20 years experience in
the
infectious disease field
our expertise is in vitro immunology in
a rnd context
but at the highest level of quality we
work with all type of products
antibodies self-directed products arena
and dna vaccine
viruses including oncolytic virus
and small molecule we have recognized
expertise and we are involved in four
international r d projects funded
by the european union union sorry
it took quite a long time uh to get a
market authorization for the rockets
starting with the stargate selection
working on genomics and proteomics then
lead discovery
uh with asset development high
throughput screening medicinal chemistry
with library development physical
chemistry and healthy click screening
before moving to in vitro screening and
in vivo screening
before the first in many applications in
clinical trials
that will hopefully lead to the com to
the commercial acceptance of the product
we believe that with high quality in
vitro screening you will be
able to move faster from inventory
screening to clinical trials
and also to reduce the use of animals
you are probably familiar with this nice
scheme from the chain paper
showing the complex interaction that can
occur in the tumor
microenvironment between the immune
cells and the tumor cells
but also with the different immune cells
together
at human expert we have different sa
focusing on t-cells and myriad essay
today on the interest will be on miroid
sa and more specifically
on macrophages sa
macrophage macrophages are phagocytes
that serve as first line of defense
against pathogenic intruders
these innate immune cells mean
pro-inflammatory response to pathogen
and repair damaged tissue
the diversity of the macrophages in vivo
is quite important we can find different
type of macrophages in the different
organ and tissue
with different function so it's really
an important family
with a lot of different type of
macrophages with different function
classically in the literature we can
find a classification
a simplification of this classification
with m1 and m2 like macrophages
the m1 macrophages inhibiting the
tumor growth or the pathogen invasion
and the m2 macrophages being involved in
the healing process
the m1 macrophagic secret inos
transformatory cytokine
expressed high level of mhc2 and
cost stimulation molecule they are also
more
linked to the th1 response while the m2
macrophages
secrete high level of arginines a
cytokine like tgf beta and ugf and
xpr cd 206 and other markers like cd 163
and they are also considered to be
involved more in the th2 response
the simplification of the classification
of the macrophages is quite
useful in vitro because it corresponds
to the type of macrophages that you can
introduce
in your essay so the m1 macrophages
which depends on the
on the stimulation of antiframe gamma
and lps
and which are involved in a th one's
response as i mentioned earlier
in the m2 family you can find three
subclasses of
macrophages first the m2a
then can be induced with il-4 and il-13
which are involved in ts2 responses
like allergy then the m2b
that can be induced with immune complex
and taylor ligand
which are also involved in the h2
activation and in
immunoregulation and finally the mqc
which are induced by il-10 and which are
involved in immunoregulation and in
tissue modeling this mqc
are often used as a surrogate for the
tumor
tumor associated macrophages
you can see on the right on the slides
that these different macrophages
are activated three different pathways
through the different transition factor
for an example the antechrome gamma can
induce
the that one and telephone respondent
factor
pathway in the macrophages while on the
m2 for example you have the il4
that will induce the phosphorylation of
type 6 and the activation
of the gene depending of this transition
factor
an important notion to know about the
macrophages is the plasticity of the
macrophages
this concept has been historically found
in the literature
mentioning that macrophages can be
switched from a phenotype to another one
then an m1 macrophages can become m2
like macrophages
and turn on them to like macrophages can
become an m1 like macrophages
recently a more complex model has been
proposed
to to understand different type of
macrophages
which is related to the ontogeny and
mentioning that it's not
so much passivity of the macrophages
that we can observe
but different recruitment of different
origin that will lead to a more complex
description of the macrophages currently
literature we find paper defining both
models
one that stands that macrophages can be
a finely different state to successfully
find in different states and another one
thing that is different cell
a different origin resulting in
different recruitment at the tumor size
for the examples
so to look in the tumor microenvironment
so you can find macrophages
so the temps the tumor-associated
macrophages usually these macrophages
has immune suppressive properties and
also fertilize the tumor growth through
angines
the goal of some therapeutics is to
repolarize or to change its macrophages
to more prone thermal inflammatory
phenotypes
that will induce immunostimulation an
increased antigen presentation
and a t cell activation leading to a
tumor regression
there is a lot of different mechanisms
that can be targeted
to re-educate the macrophages and go
from this immunosuppressive
phenotype to a more pro-inflammatory
phenotype
so for example you can use d4t agonist
to trigger the expression of
pro-inflammatory cytokine
or just use pd-1 or pdl-1 blockade
to interfere with the immune separation
mechanism
used by the macrophages to suppress the
t-cells response
there is a lot of different mechanisms
that can be targeted by the macrophages
you can see on this slide that there is
a lot of molecules that are currently
under investigation
currently testing clinical trials today
we will focus on the drug
that can affect the polarization of the
macrophages or their interaction
with the t cell
so we will focus on three type of said
the first one is the m1 m2 like
macrophages polarization
which can be used to affect to assess
the effect of test compound on
macrophages polarization
or to assess the effect of a test
compound on macrophages phenotype and
function
the first one is a model that uh
study the effect on the macrophage
recruitment and differentiation
and the other one the effect of a test
compound on the already differentiated
and activated macrophages
and so that will interfere with their
function
to use model that another model is the
m2-like suppressive sa
which allow us to assess the effect of a
test compound on the suppressive
properties of m2-like macrophages
and their interaction with the t-cells
and the latest essay that we will be
discussing today is the phagocytes of
this essay
where we can assess the effect of a test
compound on the macrophages
phagocytic activities
but to perform um such essays all start
with a high quality self so happy cells
mean happy essay
like it is shown in this nice scheme
from miltini
so the quality of the primary cells mean
that you
will reduce the variability and increase
the reproducibility
of the results the quality means that
you need high viability and high
functionability of this
self that are the most critical region
in your essay
to ensure this high quality you need to
proceed
to pro to use standardized procedure for
sampling shape
shipping isolation clear preservation
tooling
and handling of the self
to assess the functionality of the
primary cells and so the quality of the
primary cells at immune expert
we use the stimulation over seven days
of the pbmc with a polyclonal simulation
so an of cd3 or
with a naive antigen so the key only
invert immediate in this case
after the seven days of culture we are
measuring the proliferation of the cd4 t
cells and the cat cells to assess the
responsiveness of the cells
this proliferation is measured with the
incorporation of edu
[Music]
and the redo is performed by flow
cytometry with the mac content
you can observe that when not stimulated
there is a
very low percentage of proliferating
cells then
when stimulated with a kelh we observe
that more than two percent of the
cd40 cells are proliferating meaning
that the cell preparation
has functional cells and so that the
cells can be used
in downstream essay
another important part of our quiz
of our qc procedure to assess the
quality of
pbmc it's also a population analysis
to determine the different proportion of
the different population
it can be quite interesting because for
example the percentage of monocytes can
vary
from one donor to another and for male
with sa and macrophages
you we will select donor with a higher
percentage of monocytes
meaning that we can have more cells and
perform more condition more condition
or more essay with the same donor
preparation
so to work with macrophages it all
starts with monocyte
isolation the monocyte can be isolated
from different source
the from cryopreserve pbmc but also from
wall blot all the catherines
the local pharisees can be quite
interesting for many lead essays
because they usually present higher
percentage of monocytes than
in a pbmt from world blood to isolate
the monocyte you can use different kit
using positive or negative selection in
the
result that i will present in the
following satellite we only use
cd14 positive selection with the melting
a bit
to isolate the monocytes and induce the
differentiation into macrophages
to ensure the quality of the essay i
will say it's quite important to follow
the kit recommendation so an exhibition
from two to eight degree mean and
inclusion in the fridge
not a nice it will allow you to increase
the purity but also the recovery of the
cells
at him expert we also use pre-cooled
tube for the harvesting of the cells
to avoid that the macrophage sticks to
the tube and so to lose a part
of the macrophages or the monocytes and
also it's important to use cool medium
after the isolation
once the monocyte has been isolated you
can start
proceeding to the macrophage
differentiation for the m1 line
macrophages we use six days of gmcsf
followed by two extra day of stimulation
with understand gamma
for the m2 like macrophages is sixth day
of mcsf
follow either by two day of il-4 with
together with ielts and children
to induce m2c or il4 and il13 to induce
m2a
once this micro macrophages has been
differentiated
you can access version dye by flow
cytometry
by using different marker
characteristics of the m1 or the m2 like
macrophages
it is important to know that the
macrophages are quite delicate cells
so the culture condition has to be
properly set up
this is what what the m1 or the m2 like
macrophages can
look under the microscope after the full
differentiation
the m1 like cells are highly adherent
they present long cytoplasmic extension
there is also a high risk of the medium
exertion
meaning that you will have to refresh
several times the medium during the
differentiation process
and the yield is about 15 to 30 percent
so meaning that you recover
50 to 50 percent of m1 from the monocyte
that you have been seeing
the v ability can be also quite tricky
with the m1 but i
will come back to this on the next slide
with the m2 microphages they present a
low adherence small
cytoplasmic extension the medium's
exertion risk is lower than with the m1
and the yield is also better with itself
so the m1 are highly sticky itself and
it can be quite tricky to get viable and
functional
m1 uh after the differentiation with
them
from monocytes in this slide it's an
experiment
where we try different protocols to
harvest the macrophages so either an
enzymatic method with acutas
non-enzymatic buffer or just scrapping
of the cells
we also seed 1 to 4 million cells in a
12 well plate
you can observe that if we use the
scrapping method we have a low viability
of the macrophages
if we use on the other side aquitas we
have a
higher percentage of life cells and it
is similar between the different
cell density tests in this essay with
the non-isometic buffer
the viability increases with the cell
density and is
higher than with the scrapping method
for the yell there is less variation
between the different cell density
but you can observe that with the higher
cell density the
non-arithmetic and the scrapping method
present better result than with the
lower cell
density
but this cell density can also affect
other parameters if we look at cd86
expression and macrophages you can see
that the lower the cell density is the
higher the cd86 expression has
so meaning that the cell density has
also an influence on the quality of the
macrophage that you can recover
and the expression of some
membrane marker but also the production
of cytokine
it's also important to note that the
enzymatic method
can affect the phenotype of the
macrophages and if we look at the
cd2onite
expression the acutas induce a decreased
expression of this marker
it's why we usually try to avoid to use
this enzymatic method
to harvest the macrophages
so it's really you have to depending on
the culture condition to
take the better compromise the best
condition
to get life cells functional cells and
expressing the right marker at the right
level
so it's quite complicated with the
macrophages and
atom experts will usually use the
non-semitic buffer to access the
macrophages
and the cell density from two to three
million
cell parallel in a twelve wealth plate
once you get these macrophages you still
have to work with them
but also perform to characterize them
the flow cytometry is quite an important
tool to characterize the macrophages
but these cells are highly
autofluorescence
meaning that you have a high signal with
non-noble cells in the uv violet or blue
laser
as you can see on this dot plot
then it's quite important to use the
relevant control so the phrase minus one
to be sure of the background staining
head or the background of the presence
of the macrophages
and to select the right positive signal
the rear antibodies from melting can
really help in this case
because they will increase the
resolution the monocytes and macrophages
also express cd16 cd42 and cd64
meaning that they are more successful to
the specific
stealing by with the test antibody
so you have to use fc block order
antibodies that will allow you to get
rid of this problem
note that we know how to get this
macrophages
we will go further in the essay that we
can perform with them
so in the m1 m2 polarization essay
we can perform the dsa in two
configurations
in the first one the test compound are
isolated from the mono
from the month size isolation step to
assess their effect on the
differentiation process
but when the macrophages are fully
differentiated
we can harvest them watch them and
reside them in presence of the test
compound
to assess the effect of the test
compound on the function and the
phenotype of the macrophages
so this is an example of the kind of
result that you can obtain
with an analysis of the cell surface
marker expression on m1
m2a and m2c
if you look at the expression of cd163 a
marker that is characteristic of the m2
like macrophages
you can observe that we only have an
expression in the m2 like macrophages
and this expression is higher in the m2c
cd209 is another marker used to
characterize the m2 macrophages
as it is expressed by m2a and m2c but
the
very low expression is detected on m1
cd 206 and cd 210r
are expressed by both type of
macrophages but usually the expression
is higher in m2 like macrophages
for the m1 like macrophages we usually
look at a
co-simulation molecule but you can also
look at the
msg2 class image mhc class 2 expression
to check these macrophages because the
expression on this marker
is usually higher on m1 than on m2
you can also observe that the m to a are
between the m1 and the m2c
for the expression of customization
molecule
and finally we also like to check the
pd1 expression as we can use it
as a controller summoner i say and it is
expressed by all type of macrophages but
usually the expression is higher in m2c
which are the most suppressive
macrophages
in this example of a vaporization essay
we treat
fully parallelized m1 m2a or m2c with
interferon gamma and lps
on the cell surface marker we don't see
so much variation
we mostly observe an increase in the 86
expression on the m2am2c
treated with interferon gamma and if we
look at the cytokine production below
you can observe that
alden is not produced by m1 we find a
production in the m2a and
m2c macrophages and this expression is
decreased
in the cells treated with antiframe
gamma
we like if we look at the il-12 p70 as
expected it's a it is produced by the m1
like macrophages
a little bit by the m2a but no
production is detected in the m2c
condition
but with the l12 p70 we don't see some
other variation
with the different treatment that we use
in this essay
so this is the example of the
reparalization essay and i will come
back later
with an example of a polarization essay
where we use a
test component that has been published
in the literature
with this macrophages we can also
perform a separate services so
to access the suppressive effect on the
macrophages on the cd4
t cells this is a can also be used with
cdt cells or plant t cells
but today i will only discuss examples
involving the cd40 cells
so what we are doing is still the same
protocol to introduce the
differentiation of m1 or m2 like
macrophages
and then performing the culture of this
cells with autologous cd4 positive t
cells
in presence of the test compound and a
cdpc28 agonist to
induce an activation of the t-cells
after five days of co-culture we can
measure the proliferation
of the cytokine production from the cd40
itself
it's important to note that the
macrophysis has a phagocytic activity so
if you use bees coated with agonists or
c3h3
you can observe a separation of the
response just because the macrophages
will phagocize a bit
so it's better to use a soluble
activator
of cd38 in this kind of essay to induce
an activation of the
t-cells and be able to assess the
suppressive activity of the macrophages
we also usually use a ratio of one to
five so
one piece one macrophages for five
tissues
to access the t-cell proliferation
we use a proliferation dye so we prefer
to use a violet proliferation dye
because they have a lower
toxicity and also allow to have a higher
resolution
as we use the replication index as a
measure of the replication of the
of the t cells it's also important to
include the visibility die in the
readout
to get rid of the dead self and for the
city for stinning
it's better to use a fluorochrome that
will allow you to allow you to
discriminate
the c40 cells from the macrophages so to
avoid the blame of the autophagons of
the macrophages
that will contaminate the cd4 response
so on most cytometer you have a red
laser and so the apc can be
a good choice to for the city for
labeling and to discriminate the c40
cells
from the macrophages
so this is the kind of result that you
can get to share macrophage to perceive
essay
if we look on the right at the cytokine
secretion
on the cytokine secretion so for the
interferon gamma you can observe that we
have a higher equation of antenna in the
cd40 cell alone
and the similar level in presence of the
m1 like macrophages
in presence of the m2 line macrophages
we have an important decrease of this
secretion
meaning that the macrophages suppress
the t-cell activation
if we look on the left at the
proliferation
you have in grey the level of the cd4 uh
this algorithm
you can observe that with the in
presence of the amount the
proliferation is slightly higher but we
have an important decrease of the
proliferation
in light blue in presence of the m2
macrophages
and you can see that in this example the
proliferation stop after two
cycles of replication while we go up to
six or
seven repetition cycle in the cd4 t cell
alone or in presence of the m1 like
macrophages
so meaning that we were able to suppress
the activation of the divorce itself
with this two essay we perform a case
study with
lil herbico so this is a pre publication
from 2018
and so in this publication using mostly
most model they show that if you block
lillerb2 you can prevent the
differentiation
of monocytes into m2 like macrophages
but that this little b2 can also act as
a
checkpoint inhibitor specific of the
mirror itself
so we do two essays using this blocking
antibody for
level 2 first a polarization essay and
then a suppressive essay
so in the polarization essay we had the
anti-label antibody from the monocyte
isolation step
and this is the kind of result that we
obtain
so if we look at cd163 and cd209
expression
two markers which are characteristic of
the m2 like macrophages
in the control condition you can observe
that in the first donor we have a purity
of the m2 of
86.7 and in the second donor of 92.5
in presence of the lillard b2 antibody
we decrease this percentage to 49.8
in the first donor and to 68.6 in the
second donor
so meaning that the addition of this
test compound
allow us to prevent the differentiation
of monocytes into m2 like macrophages
and that this essay can be used to
assess the effect of a test compound on
the macrophages polarization
then with the same test antibody we
perform the m2 suppressive
essay but in this case the little bit
antibody was only had
during the culture of the macrophages
with the t cells not from the monophyte
step
only during the culture
and so as usual we perform a qc of the
macrophages that
check that we have nice m1 and m2 like
macrophages that they expressed the
right marker
and it was the case so for example an
expression of cd163 only and to like
macrophages
while the co-stimulation molecules were
highly expressed on
m1-like macrophages
so we measured the antenna gamma
secretion after a five day of
code culture you can observe that we
have high secretion
in presence of the cd4 with the cd40
cell alone stimulated with the cd3 cd28
agonist in presence of the m1 in the
two first donor we don't have a
significant
effect and in the third donor we have a
slight decrease
but that is
that was caused by an exhaustion of the
medium so the minion was completely
exhausted
and so it decreased at the end the
secretion of the hunger map the cd40
itself
if we look at the m2 conditions so in
this case we don't have an exhaustion of
the medium
but we have an important decrease of the
interferon gamma secretion
in comparison to the or the cd4 or cd4
plus m1 condition
in the cocco 2 we also test three
antibody
sodium divorce a clinical on tpd-1
delilah b2
antibody and an unspeedier one and with
the three
antibody we were able to increase the
interference gamma secretion
in the cd4 m2 culture and so to
interfere with the specific property of
the macrophages
if we look at the proliferation in the
same essay
we have a similar effect of the cd4 and
cd4 press m1
so 100 proliferation sometimes slight
decrease because of the exertion of the
medium
but with the test compound we don't see
so much effect
just in donor two a significant increase
in presence of the lillard b2 antibody
and in the one a trend to increase but
not significant in presence of the
little bit to antibody
so altogether this results show that
this essay can be used
to assess the effect of a test compound
on the suppressive function of the
macrophages
so that this suppressive assay can be
used to screen molecules
that are targeting the
suppressive mechanism used by the
m2-like macrophages
to suppress the t-cell activation in the
tumor micro environment
the last essay i will discuss today is
the adcp
ss so anti-depend antibody dependent
cell phagocytosis essay
so in this essay we induce a
macrophage differentiation and then we
perform agriculture of these macrophages
with the target cells in presence of the
test compound
and we can measure the phagocytosis of
the target cells by the macrophages
in the following slide i will present
the result based on flow
cytometry readout but we
installed this week the first intuicide
a65
in belgium and we will also add this ssa
with
inquisite readout
and so in the test studies that we
perform at a immune expert
we perform m2c differentiation so
mcsf then if one l10 ntjs beta treatment
we co-culture uh with these macrophages
with the target cell which in this case
are
b cells so cd20x press itself labeled
with a proliferation dye
and then we use the hydroxy map as a
positive control so
knight g1 anti-cd20 antibody
so targeting the b cells and
for the result uh we use the flow
cytometry
so as the target cells are labeled with
a proliferation dye
and if we use the cd11b as a marker for
the m2 macrophages
it's meant that the double positive
cells will be the macrophages that has
been
that has phagocytes this phagocyte
that has performed the phagocytosis of
the target cell lines
so this is the kind of result that you
can obtain so you have the
macrophage only with no phagocytes as
expected
with the human igd-1 isotype control we
trigger some
phagocytic activity by the macrophysis
which is
expected as the this antibody will
increase
the activity of the macrophages through
the fc receptor present
on the acrophages and then with the
rituximab sodium tcg20
we increase the percentage of
psychosis as this because we also
increase the specificity of these
faculties as this thanks to the antibody
targeting the cell lines
meaning that this essay can be used to
affect the effect of a
molecule interfering with the
phagocytosis property of the macrophages
and for example with igd-1 form of
antibodies
so with all the essays that i present
today
you can screen a lot of different
mechanisms study a lot of different
mechanisms and molecule
targeting this mechanism that can have
an important function
in the thermal micro environment
moreover all this assay has been
developed with human cells
and so i will are more representative to
the human system
as the overall system can be for example
the individual using mouse
i would like to finish by a few words
about
the nexus group so immune expert as i
mentioned earlier
joined an excellent group in march gcr
the nexus group has different facilities
in europe in
canada and the u.s with different
laboratories with different
capacity so for example in canada
in laval they have b cell two bsl to
plus laboratories and animal facilities
with a focus on infectious disease and
immune oncology
the seattle site has state of the art
laboratories with a focus on metabolic
disease and oncologic disease
we also have a partnership with public
health in grants
we give with access to bcl-2b cell 3
and b cell 4 laboratories and animal
facilities in the
leadership of world-class scientists
and so through all this front sight and
all this different capacity
[Music]
the next list has services in lead
optimization in vivo screening in visual
screening protein science
and clinical trials and large-scale
advances
meaning that we can help you from the
discovery and early discovery
development to the fires
three clinical trials
if you wish to receive or infer donated
to contact us
on the email address
[Music]
and for adminexpert.com i would like to
thank you once again for attending to
this webinar and i will be happy to take
any question
thank you very much
thank you to beau for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question
is do you culture your cells under
physioxic conditions
if not why not no that's not something
we
are doing and that's not something we
have done with the data present today
that's something we have tried with a
specific incubator called the avatar
that allowed to cultivate the
macrophages in the
hypoxic condition it was giving nice
results but the
issue with this kind of system is that
most of the time you have really a
limited number of
plate that you can cultivate in the
system and so for screening purpose into
screening a large number of molecule and
test condition
that that was not fitting our
application so it's why we choose to
for the woman to stick to the regular
incubator
okay thank you and let me ask you
another question here
do you remove beads before use of cells
in assays
no with the milky beads it's not needed
because they're biodegradable and not
toxic so they will be
quickly they will quickly disappear from
the culture medium
but if something that's bother you there
is also some
negative selection kit available for the
isolation of the monocytes
and we have to try them in our essence
also working quite well to generate the
macrophages
okay next question which microscopy is
used and what magnification for m1 and
m2 morphology
yes so on the picture i showed today
it's a classical like contrast
phases microscope that we use and i
think it's a
200 time magnification but uh
i would have to confirm that but i think
it's a 200 time magnification that we
use in a
classical microscopy okay
thank you to beau next question which
non-enzymatic buffer do you recommend
so for the harvesting of macrophages we
usually use a ps edta based buffer
and for specific reference we use the
versin buffer
for the harvesting of the macrophages
that i present in this
in this webinar
okay and our next question is
what ratio of macrophage to cd8 t cells
do you use
so the one that we have been test that
we have tested
is the same for 260 40 cells and cd8
cells so it's still a ratio one to five
so one macrophages for five t cells
and it gives similar results in the
different uh with the difference the
population of these cells
okay next question
do you prefer coated anti-cd3 or soluble
anti-cd3 to stimulate t
cells in a suppressive assay and why
yes we prefer soluble anticd3 and for
two reasons
so the first one is that you from s8 to
sl you have less variation with soluble
cd3 because with the coating
it's a quite tricky step that can
trigger some variation from essay to set
so you're
not always sure to have scored the same
amount of antibody
and the second thing is that we usually
sit first the macrophages on the plate
before the t-cells and so there is a
risk that the macrophages by
sticking to the plate will hide the cd3
antibodies
for the access to the t-cells so it's
why we usually first see the macrophages
then that itself and then we had the
cd380
differentiator agonist to activate the
okay t-cells question do you have a
positive control for macrophage
polarization or suppression assay
so yes so is the control we we show in
the different uh
data in the webinar so for the
polarization and the suppression essay
we can use the anti-delirium antibody so
that will act both as a checkpoint
inhibitor but also
as an inhibition of the macro the m2
like macrophages differentiation
and in the suppressive sa you can also
use classical
checkpoint editor like on tpd1 or tpdl1
that will also have a nice effect on the
antifungal secretion
by the t-cells
okay thank you so much the next question
do you look for secreted interferon
gamma or intracellular interferon gamma
by flow
so we'll look uh to secret antistrong
gamma so
in this dataset that's represented today
by
eliza and uh is for the same reason so
it's
easier for screening purpose to look at
the secreted anti-strong gamma
than to the entrance lr1 and
we compared the macrophages alone in the
macrophages and go culture
for teachers to be sure that the main
source of anti-fungamen rsa is the
t-cells and not the macrophages
and usually we have some secretion of
anterior gamma with the m1 like
macrophages alone
but it's very low in comparison to the
culture condition
all right we've got some really great
questions here a lot of good questions
do you spike in test compounds again
during the course of the assay
so in the polarization essay when we are
refreshing the medium uh we have again
uh
the test compound so for example in the
with the little two when we are
refreshing the medium or adding new
cytokines
we also add the antibody again but in
the case of the suppressive essay we
don't
spike the test compound during the essay
so it's just
at the beginning of the cocado and then
we don't have it anymore
okay thank you next question
have you tried inducing tumor-associated
macrophages using
tumor-conditioned media no that's not
something we have done
yet because in our application we need
to have quite stable and reproducible
results
and this kind of consumer tumor
conditionated media can induce more
variation in the essay
so for the woman we have only stick to
the cytokine cocktail
differentiation
in the next question have you tried the
combination treatment of optivo and anti
lil rb2 on macrophages
no that's not something that we have
done yet but
we think to include it in our next essay
to see if there is a synergic effect
between these two compounds
different targets targeting different
mechanisms it could have
a nice synergic effect but we don't know
yet
okay do you have
experience with other immune cells like
microglia
no i don't it's not something that i
have experience with
okay what are the polarization
efficiencies
uh so for the m1 and m2 light
macrophages when we are
analyzing the cell after the idea
differentiation process
in the control condition depending on
the donor we are between 80 to 95
percent
of m1 or m2 cells so it's a quite
efficient
differentiation process
and i have a few more questions here the
donors you talked about were they humans
or mice
no it's all the data present today we
were with
human donors so with pbmc from human and
vendor
monocytes from a healthy human donor
okay did you try to upsell to harvest
macrophages did you try upsell to
harvest macrophages excuse me
yes that's something that we have tried
it increa it is increasing the
the yield and the number of macrophages
that you can get
but what we observed is for the m1 like
microphones
the expression of the customization
marker was uh
less important on the treated with the
upsell
and they were not working so nicely in
the suppression sas control so we
prefer to go back to the regular plate
even
if the yield end of the ability is a bit
lower with this regular plate
did you try to stimulate t cell with
immodc in the suppressive assay
that's something that we haven't done
yet but uh
that we have considered to do a few
times but we haven't had the opportunity
to do it
yet but i believe it should work uh
if uh to use a cd40 cells or c8 cells
from one donor
the macrophages from the same donors and
the dc from
nalogenic donors to induce an activation
of the
uh of the t-cells it's just then the uh
because the checkpoint individual like
pd1 can be also expressed by dendritic
cells
so it might also have an influence on
the essence and increase observe
might be also due to the dc action and
not only to the macrophages action
it's why for the moment we only stick to
models with
macrophages and t cells to be sure that
we are targeting the molecule expressed
on the macrophages and not another cell
type
okay thank you next question is there an
upregulation of some
m2 markers while polarizing polarizing
macrophages to m1 and vice versa
in a proper ammunition it's possible so
for an example
with some test component like the lps
that
will increase the expression of some m1
light marker like
the cd86 or the cd cd80 in some donor
you can also
increase the expression of cd163 or
cd206
so it's possible and it's why it's also
important to look at the function of the
macrophages
and for example to the cytokine profile
secretion so that will help you to
understand if it's
trigger more with inflammatory or
intercommateric polarization of the
macrophages
okay we've got one more question here
mature macrophages do show vacuoles
i could not see that in your images that
you showed
how long were they cultured with
cytokines
so with the activation marker it was for
48
hours so if we look at with a bigger
manifest
magician you can probably look uh
see this uh this structure but what we
mostly observe at first view
with the maturation of the macrophages
is the increase of the
dendrite and the cytoplasmic
approachment and also of the cytokine
secretion
and the exertion of the medium because
they become quite
active okay and we have another question
that just came in
have you generated macrophages from
frozen pbmcs
and if yes how did they behave compared
to fresh
and did you add differentiation cocktail
right away or one day later
so in order that i present today is
macrophages
generated from frozen pbmc
we are comparing a few we say the frozen
versus the fresh
pbmc and we didn't see so much
difference in the
essay shown today and we always directly
had the the the site okay so we directly
isolate the
profi and then put them in culture with
the cytokine we never tried to wait one
day before adding the the size again for
to reduce the differentiation of the
macrophages
okay thank you to bo looks like we don't
have any more questions do you have any
final comments for
our audience uh
i will just thank everyone to for
attending to this webinar and for the
interesting
q and a session so thank you very much
and thank you again to beau for your
time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor miltonia biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye